games we've been playing them forever
but why games are fun okay but what else
nature takes play very seriously play
offers safe practice for learning the
skills you need to do things that in
nature may even relate to your survival
[Music]
this is Matt oh hi I'm Matt Miller and I
think you should ditch that textbook and
this is Joe and camp guys my name is Kay
matada Rome and my name is Joe taro
we are avid game enthusiasts these guys
are experts in finding real world
lessons in existing games games like
clash of clans and they're using these
lessons to turn game play into a
universal learning tool through a theory
called constructivism constructivism
basically says you need to be put in
situations that allow you to construct
your understanding of a particular topic
or phenomenon we're constructing we're
making up what we know the world to be
that's kind of constantly changing we're
adding new things into our paradigm of
what we think the world is and that's
really what education is all about there
is a third grade on a field trip to get
first-hand knowledge of their questions
in science if we have play pulled into
all of that if we if we use games to be
able to learn in that way that's that
inherently interesting inherently fun
way to do that but they don't even
realize that they're learning when they
are that could be true of video games as
well depending on the type of video game
games that you really want to start with
that have the high ROI our cooperative
games in a cooperative game the game
itself is trying to defeat you and you
do need to work together and coordinate
your efforts
clash of clans is a good example of a
cooperative game because you have a clan
you want your other clan mates to do
well however all boats rise
as you play some of these games you see
the very specific skills and
competencies that can be developed if
you leverage the game intentionally in
that direction
clash of clans was unavoidable in my
class and of course as a teacher I
started to think about how could that
play into my lesson and so I started to
create sort of like a review game and so
whenever they would answer questions
correctly the order in points but the
thing that came from clash of clans was
they built up those points to be able to
buy things and they loved it it's an
investment portfolio and it supports
your choice making terms of long term
investment and savings short term
investment and that's not just for kids
you see it with kids but you also see it
with adults adults can get better at
this stuff by playing these types of
games so when you break it down to
individual mechanics you think about in
terms of resources what are the
resources available to me so clash has
elixir dark elixir gold clash is really
good at presenting choices for both
immediate gain and delayed game so
there's that famous marshmallow
experiment where you put a marshmallow
in front of a kid and say okay you can
eat the marshmallow now or you can wait
and if you keep that marshmallow in ten
minutes
I'll give you another marshmallow and
you'll have two instead of one some kids
are able to delay the gratification and
say okay I'm gonna wait for that second
marshmallow that's great others like
look I'm eating your marshmallow oh I
love the marshmallow experiment you're
delayed gratification and our society is
something that all of us really struggle
with if you know why you're playing it
and you know what you're getting out of
it and sometimes you can learn lessons
by playing video games that you can't
learn a lot of other ways there's so
much available right now that you can
pull off the shelf or download and
develop some ideas about how that
connects to skills in the workplace you
don't have to go all the way
the chance to play is essential to the
well-being of all regardless of age
surely the games may change over time
but we and our desire to play together
and have immersive experiences and be in
community we've been doing that forever
having people play cooperative games
where it enhances their communication
Hans's leadership cooperative games are
a rich vein to mine in that regard and
way more effective and our trust fall
yes yeah
[Music]